guillaume dustan je pense que pour vous
une interview psi serait assez bienvenu
on ne bouge pas pendant les teens galles
on ne bouge pas pendant qu on ne bouge
pas pendant le digger
[Applaudissements]
bien l'interview psy est ce que vous
êtes mytho j'ai peur vous soyez tous là
j'ai peur j'ai peur que vous ayez
j'espère que vous ayez une croix dans
chaque cas allez courage bah non non je
veux mais tu sais pas du tout maintenant
je suis vraiment le meilleur écrivain de
france voilà donc vergallo vous êtes les
galops vous le reconnaissez
non j'ai le sens de ma valeur d'accord
est ce que vous êtes parano extrêmement
mais je pense que j'ai vraiment de
bonnes raisons de l'être
pourquoi parce que tout le monde n'en
veut pas du tout on n'attend pas c'est
étonnant en tous les cas pas moi gentil
excuse schizo bas c'était un peu quand
je me rends compte c'est trop tard est
ce que vous êtes maso non vous n'avez
pas souffrir non gelée était
cliniquement 1
mais je ne suis plus quoi parce que j'ai
beaucoup travaillé
c'est très difficile à soigner est ce
que vous êtes sado depuis que je suis
plus masos chez des opportunités pour
l'être et j'essaie de résister je m'en
passe que vous êtes sous l'eau bah oui
évidemment est ce que vous êtes trop co
ben non malheureusement est gros lolos
non j'aimerais pas lire parce que les
peluches et les oreilles mon père mais
mon chien je suis bi refoulé c'est à
dire que
voilà c'est que depuis qu'elles s'y là
comme je trouve que c'est vraiment trop
trop trop trop lourd pour moi de coucher
avec une femme parce que c'est risqué
magna
j'ai plus jamais nos relations avec les
femmes
alors que s'il n'y avait pas ça je pense
que ça m'arrive attend donc vous
pourriez être gros lolos en fait ouais
le vibro je fais ça depuis des années
triaud moi j'aime plutôt 4 et plus
géronto j'aime reviendront le saut avec
moi exhibo sens de la mode c'est est ce
que vous êtes de sa mode est ce que vous
êtes travail en compte
l'otage si vous êtes travelo non est ce
que vous êtes adamo oui complètement
allez-vous shaman king
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous êtes mégalo oh non pas
du tout non vous êtes mito non plus
d'être parano noc schizo sauf quoique ça
tout le monde est un peu septembre un
homme enfin bon moi je suis un peu de
seins quand même
ouais le bruit beaucoup de défauts mais
le fait d'être si klaus est par
définition un peu schizo cyclo un peu
oui les cyclos vu que c'est ce qu'ils
ont une formule est maso non pas du tout
vous aimez pas qu'on vous fasse mal aux
noms a bon dos mais alors là il ya des
gens qui adorent ça oui oui pareil wii
balance alors changé c'est tellement con
enfin bon est ce que vous êtes sa dos à
dos n'ont plus selon me faire du bien et
non moi j'ai piqué la poule est sympa
mais non vous êtes homo ou alors on
avait tout peut arriver
tout peut arriver là tout peut arriver
vous étiez petit au maroc pourquoi vous
dites ça a comme au body coller la paix
aux français aussi vous avez d'avoir des
propositions aux français je veux dire
donc je ne me suis jamais fait en papa
août et si vous dis que je vous dis
c'est un peu verdun de ce côté là mais
il y avait beaucoup
il y avait beaucoup de domofrance et de
gens qui avaient beaucoup de talent et
on allait vous savez ils ont tendance à
vous féminisé et on m'avait féminisé
lors d'une tournée parce que j'étais
avec vous appelez la galabru non en main
on m'appelait parce que j'étais robert
hirsch il avait beaucoup de l'esprit et
m'appeler rosa pichon et rosa pichon et
bien vous savez on se sent un peu femme
à ce moment là c'est pas aller plus loin
non non non non on est resté à rosas bon
on est ce que vous êtes gros lolos gros
lolos à wimille
je suis aussi petit lolo
je suis le long complet voilà c'est un
corsage tous extraordinaires et je
regrette de ne pas avoir plus bas
quoique oui est ce que vous êtes trio
trio
attention enfin je vais pas être faut il
faut des rejets dans mon temps à
l'époque trio j'ai goûté ouais c'est pas
mauvais la fecq deux femmes pas bon mais
canon parce que vous êtes exhibo non pas
du tout exito en acteur est toujours
existant en eau qui me gêne c'est le
principe de cette interview il comprend
bien celle de labro le gala voilà
certains films on le voit poil à non
c'est vrai s'il y en a mais vous l'avez
loupé j'étais figurant dans la bataille
buffet est vite le débat sur les
pompiers et ont passé des clés liés
comme on appelle ça le conseil de
révision
donc comme j'étais figurant en zambie
tous nus et moi j'ai eu le malheur de me
trouvais juste à la porte du médecin
donc pour raccorder au mal et c'est là
toute une journée tout nu avec la script
qui dotés tous les étals travelo de
[ __ ] n'ont jamais essayé
gt gt d'acajou faut que j'étais enfin
bon travelo est commun
femmes et acteur lalliot tognazzi devais
me rouler une pelle
oui il a refusé pourquoi il à dire me
voyante et aurore launay très bien
compris
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous êtes recompte rocco et
ses frères
encore que ces frais des indes rocco
siffredi rocco siffredi ouais qu'est-ce
qu'il ne connaissait pas en quoi c'est
pas dit non vous connaissez pas encore
si près des lignes de bus qui prie de
m'excuser mais je suis un poney la
campagne qu'est ce que c'est rocco
siffredi sait pas se taper un poney à
défrayer un peu tout
c'est un type qui est monté comme un âne
allons à non non non j'ai pas de détails
vous dire mais c'est pas rocco c'est par
au coccyx poko h et pour cause est ce
que vous êtes
adamo à j'adore a d'abord est ce que
vous êtes disco au blond qui est plus de
mon âge je crois va essayer
ce gars là
raconte vitry j'ai besoin marion pas
alors pour évaluer votre vraie
personnalité on va vous faire une
interview psy vous êtes prête à la
bouche pendant les ting
[Musique]
merci nadine je trouve extraordinaire je
suis le parcours voilà nadine de
rothschild je comprends pourquoi être
non vous à pourquoi ça s'est si bien
passée avec edmond pendant ces trente
sept ans c'est à dire vous êtes la femme
idéale je joue mise en guinée merci
voilà et à frédéric idée est ce que dans
soumise une connotation péjorative que
je viens franchement je n'apprécie pas
obéi singes disons frédéric bon ne vous
mentez pas insultants envers la baronne
du tout bien frédéric vous êtes prête
alors interview psy c'est facile est ce
que vous êtes mytho pas vraiment non non
non mégalo
pas vraiment non plus paranos parano
quand j'ai un peu bu ou quand j'ai un
peu fumé jordi gêne pas que vos
émissions position sur le cas ben ali
d'accord d'accord hervé il faut parler
un peu de josé cabanis le sang par le
domaine je sais quel prix renaudot en 66
né en 1922 à toulouse josé cabanis
l'auteur de l'âge ingrat
voilà c'est vrai nom n'en parle jamais
marre on parle jamais nous devons croire
débours je refuse qu'on parle de ce
grand jeu celle inquiète je sais pas
vous excuser ce qu'ils ont je pense pas
non maso mais the way à alger mais qu'on
vous fasse mal non j'aime pas je me fais
moi même
ah ouais donc ça suffit toi je voulais
tenter un truc est ce que vous aimez
faire mal c'est un peu sado non pas du
tout non je vous êtes homo un peu eva
par rapport à ce qu'on imaginait quoi
vous avez échappé dans ma main et en tma
je vous en remercie mille fois oui moi
je vais vous dire moi j'ai l'impression
ça c'est mon avis personnel mais j'ai
l'impression que toutes les filles sont
un peu même celles qui se lave ou pas
ouais je crois que pour un mec sait plus
mais après l'émission s'arrête
juste
[Musique]
moi je reste tranquille n'est pas non
c'est pas non est ce que vous êtes trio
ça peut olalalala jamais dire jamais je
n'ai jamais dit on se pince beigbeder
va-t-il s'en remettre je ne suis pas sûr
parce que par un mot vous iriez dans des
boîtes échangistes tous les samedis
soirs vous aurait répondu quoi tous les
samedis soirs non un samedi sur deux non
même un samedi sur deux samedis par mois
non je dirais si l'histoire tirée une
expérience de temps en temps why not
pourquoi pas français baghi je te
félicite la vie est beaucoup mieux que
toi je vous êtes exhibo quelque part
relais un peu puisque on passe à la
téloche
enfin vous balader pas à poil devant
votre fenêtre pour les voisins et tout
ça ça vous pouvez passer l'info l'info
non non mais non
non non non non non non non non vous
aimez bien ça mais vous n'êtes pas
d'infos dire j'aime l'amour mais jules
non je suis pas là pas au point d'être
nymphomane voilà ça tout clermont non
voilées freiner la nymphomane qui est en
vous voilà parce que vous êtes je
connais mieux que moi même est ce que
vous êtes vibro un vibro de temps en
temps un oh là là là
est ce que vous êtes porno vous regardez
les cassettes pornos car c'est chaud
c'est super bidonnage
ah ben on a vraiment changé je lance un
appel trouver un réalisateur qui sache
faire un film porno bien un truc
qu'excitant sympa vrai je sais pas ce
que ça c'est gros naze quoi des nanas
qui sont là qui gémissent cie perfo
voyons ce par l usine on secoure quoi
vraiment je comprends que quelque part
ça excite plus de gens de regarder des
reality truc c'est vrai quelque part
dans loft story un film de marc dorcel
vous choisissez quoi au nom love story
c'est vraiment trop un espace pas grand
chose non mais je dirais que je sais pas
à la cassette qui s'est vendue sous le
bras pamela anderson dans un voyage de
jean marie ça doit être sympa
voilà je pense que sa détection à calais
bah c'est quand même plus sympa que
virginie pour de vergy connaît s'agit
connaissaient laetitia là nous contacter
il faut s'intéresser mst maman c'est que
tu tournes
bien dernière question est la plus
importante d'une certaine façon est ce
que vous êtes adamo à damas
non c'est pas vrai c'était avant mieux
payés alors qu'irna 10 rebonds soir soit
reconnaissait le principe on va faire
l'interview psy ah ouais c'est
l'interruption ne bouge pas pendant le
jingle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est à présent vous fermez là où tu es
très con c'est que les billets pour la
prochaine discipline j'ai pas pensé oui
tu prendras calais olivier tu es con
comme un communiqué alors est ce que tu
es sado ouais j'aime bien faire mal
j'aime bien pensé le bout des seins maso
ouais temps en temps j'aime bien me
faire passer le bout des seins claustro
claustro non pas du tout au contraire
j'adore être pas de salle ont enfermé la
jazz heures être enfermé tous à jouer
mythos mitumba oui je me prends pour
thierry ardisson donc sunnito schizo
schizo bah oui je suis quatre
personnages à la fois je suis un ami
avait écrit que j'étais à la fois que je
voulais être daniel filipacchi patrick
sabatier et paul morand et finalement
j'étais un peu des trois aujourd'hui
chez un peu plus thierry ardisson parano
de moins en moins de parano mais c'est
vrai pendant des années je pensais que
tout le monde disait du mal de moi puis
un jour la profession fait décerner un 7
d'or est donc depuis je sais que tout le
monde est dehors les spas jean-luc expo
parlant et guigou et j'aime bien balader
à poil et mes enfants me le reproche de
la dispora tué mes enfants me laurent
cros raveleau travelo non je me suis
habillé une fois en filles dans bad
minuit aux bains douches et ça m'allait
pas non non fétiche aux as j'aime bien
oui j'aime bien des petits épisodes j'ai
des petits souvenirs les petits zone
nord maintenant je pourrais pas faire
l'amour avec mon cheval parce qu'il ya
une trop grosse [ __ ] ragots pardon
ragots est-ce que je suis radio à
j'adore les ragots et ce à tous les
ragots sur la propulsion safem le
dernier elle qui marche le mieux en ce
moment c'est le restaurant de jean luc
delarue qui s'appelle la redevance parce
que c'est vous qui l'avez payé
est ce que tu es sanglots sanglots ouais
je suis sanglots quand je vais voir le
film de joe louis et bacri le goût des
autres ou qu'on tombe de nos sept d'or
chasser sanglots masse turbo de moins en
moins mais floire bas parce que plus tu
es célèbre agent masturber
est ce que tu es populo je suis populo
moi je viens du peuple donc évidemment
j'ai aucun mépris pour le peuple puisque
j'en viens on va les serbes
il savait qu'on ne bouge pas pendant le
single on ne bouge pas pendant le bouge
pas pendant le jingle
[Musique]
vous avez bougé je sais on peut rallumer
n'ont pas bougé
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien invité jean-claude à côté de
vous voiler déroule à aller alors le
touchent la région de l'attention didier
on ne bouge pas pendant qu'on ne bouge
pas pendant le single on ne bouge pas
pendant le signal il ya alors est ce que
vous êtes
jean claude van damme est ce que vous
êtes mito me thonon je vous êtes mégalo
mais faut une tête gonflée pour avoir
pour booster son ego parce que ce fait
part de notre dans la nature humaine
si on n'est pas qu'on est bien dans la
vie si on dit qu'on est petit
qu'est-ce qu'on ait envie on va rester
petit je suis grand je suis fort je suis
beau schéma nabeul
[Applaudissements]
harry's france des droits parce que est
ce que vous êtes
est ce que vous êtes malin est ce que
vous êtes parano par un an seulement
quand il prend la 1 d'accord ok mais si
vous êtes cyclo sic non c'est tout
thymiques cyclothymique
ça a à voir avec la bicyclette être un
jour comme si un jour comme ce à quoi la
jeune femme et enfants non un jour un
quinze jours d'armes
est ce que vous êtes cyclo pour lui on a
tous deux open mais il faut pas faire
attention à ces choses là parce que si
on fait attention à ces mots on devient
esclave des mots on devient esclave le
médicament alors tous ces grosses des
grands groupes pharmaceutiques qui font
du fonds des billes under
donc on est tous normal on allait jouer
les durs ou ses hauts et bas ya le
soleil à la pluie elle aurait des
journées mais on n'est pas au départ
mais vous êtes maso à on aime tous avoir
mal est ce que vous êtes sado non
sado-maso xique laumac l'eau
est ce que vous êtes trio trio c'est
quoi ça 3 mon business on a trouvé
l'amour
1 dans l'amour mais c'est comme l'amour
d'accord parce qu'être avoir des
partenaires c'est être amoureux des
vrais partenaires dans le business des
mecs qui se tient de back to back
parce que moi j'ai connu ça quand j'ai
fait un score qui l'on met dans la merde
tous mes avocats mes agents mes amis ils
sont partis à personne qui me chercher à
l'hôpital ok alors j'ai dû raser ma tête
maintenant j'ai trouvé des gens solides
d'accord ok donc il faudrait déjà
emparée des gens qui ont des problèmes
dans la vie qui ont connu vos histoires
et mon histoire et des gens comme ça ils
savent que s'ils savent que l'on peut
pas accuser quelqu'un qui était pas ce
que sont les grandes idées mais on est
grande idée on est pas restera dans ma
salle de cours est ce que vous en pensez
ce que vous êtes
la france je voulais antiraciste en
délicieuse je suis soit 100 millions est
ce que vous vous êtes homo un homo on
est tous au monde
les puces au monde il ya un homosexuel
et à l'heure où il ya le omnia parce
qu'on s'adore moi je me regarde dans la
glace pour quoi pour avoir un beau corps
au caire l'on m'a donné on va d'un
accord et j'essaie de respecter le mieux
que je peux alors j'aime mon corps est
ce que je suis homo moi j'ai pas alors
quand je vois un homme dans une douche
qui a un beau corps judiciaire nabokov
mais là je suis homo non je crois pas
mais j'aime bien les belles choses
j'aime bien les belles semblait les
bozos rouge à vialer les gens qui sont
intelligents ou les les
j'ai même des nains qui ont qui savent
bien à plaindre donc j'aime les gens
c'est parce que je suis
mais en fait ils sont connus est ce que
vous êtes preuve le haut non vous aimez
pas des travaux non c'est pas ça non
mais ça ça m'intéresse pas de me mabille
et enfin parce que c'est un peu trop
difficile quand on s'assied pour fermer
les jambes il faut les croisés c'est une
autre femme
enfin moi je prends pas des femmes parce
que moi je viens des femmes ok ce qu'ils
m'ont fait alors les hommes du jour la
femme ceci la femme cela est la femme
dit l'homme joue comme cela la vérité
celle qu'il a fait et lui il se plaint
dès lors il ya un problème avec ça fait
maintenant en 2001 les guerres on répète
les mêmes qu'hier toujours on est
toujours au jardin d'enfants alors je
trouve qu'un homme et une femme
devraient un peu plus on s'entendre un
homme doit être sensible comme une femme
est une femme sorte comme un homme comme
ça ils ont les deux qualités ensemble ça
fait line gaming et ça fait un couple
sur moi et ma femme
ces gens qu'on mandate pour son film
bien alors sergi lopez faute de vous
mettre à poil on va vous mettre à poil
psychiquement
on va faire une interview psy vous êtes
prêts
[Applaudissements]
non cergy vous avez bougé par notre
gueule quoi vous avez bougé on rallume
serge au bouger ça bien sûr je t'en fous
c'est ainsi vous ne veut pas bouger ne
vous juge pas je te conseille d'accuser
la nuit a fait mais je vais me bouger
voilà attention
bien c'est des connards bien attention
interview psy sergi lopez est ce que
vous êtes mytho non non c'est dire si
j'ai beaucoup des mythes machin ça se
trouve il y aura plein de montgivray
votre gestion mythomane non du tout est
ce que vous êtes mégalo non non parano
non schizo non non non il y avait pas
dit qu'ils écriraient schizophrénie
c'était en fait avoir que deux
personnalités
oui donc comme cantona n'a plus cher
encore plus car il n'est plus ce qu'ils
ont est ce que vous êtes narciso a c'est
à dire je me trouve comme comme personne
ne me connaissait d'ailleurs je crois
que je suis quelqu'un kim qui me ferait
bien mais je suis étonné quand même vous
le trouvez bien le blanc surgit mais je
crains super millions et les traîtres à
quand ça vous fait vous savez bien que
tu es un petit noir pourront s'ajouter
un peu de dieu comme ça
arrive la concurrence sur ces plates et
au ctm est ce que vous êtes sadow a des
fois vous aimez bien faire mal ça dépend
du moment il ya des petites douleurs qui
peut être super sympathique vous êtes
mazouz que vous aimez avoir mal ah non
les douleurs sont sympathiques on s'est
vite les offres la commune est pas un
oiseau est ce que vous êtes exhibo non
spécialement non je vois pas on dit que
tous les acteurs on a un côté concept
peut-être est-ce que vous êtes gros
lolos way
est ce que vous êtes trio 3 samedi par
le numéro un qu'est ce que c'est le papa
du gard ces deux demandes n'ont pas de
limites
non je ne dirais pas le numéro un c'est
bien celui que vous faites l'amour à
trois
c'est une vue de l'esprit mais si vous
deviez faire l'amour à trois ou
préféreriez le fer avec deux hommes ou
deux femmes s'étaient des questions
quand même assez intime je trouve
parce que avec deux femmes vous êtes
sincère la sicile a priori je saigne
est ce que vous êtes homo non pas pour
l'instant
non non c'est vrai mais c'était moi les
choix sexuels s'est pas arrêtée
homosexuels
ouais c'est vrai il ya des gens qui
aiment blé mais qu il ya des mecs qu'il
y avait là qui me ramasser vrai c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai mais mais en
même temps je comprends bien aussi comme
vous aimez tout je suis déçu pour
l'instant était roi est ce que vous êtes
travelo a des fois un bas des fois c'est
des fois que ça m'arrive donnée déguisée
en femme
oui d'accord mais est ce que vous allez
faire l'amour et des [ __ ] enfin pas
très souvent non
non est ce que vous êtes plus tarder au
pétard dont ckoi pétards dans ça
est ce que vous êtes adamou tous les
mois est ce que vous êtes
adamo adam ans alors qu'ils disent oui
oui j'ai dit non c'est quoi ça le jeune
chanteur
m
voilà
tu m'aimes
excellent
quand
comment de gauche pendant les gardes
oui
je m'étais préparé pour l'interview
première fois je suis imprévisible quand
même les gens qui venaient ici pour la
première fois vers l'interview première
fois non mais ça c'est que jean
d'ormesson pareil s'était préparé pour
des interviews et des préservatifs des
machines et j'ai fait le questionnaire
de proust et des fautes de français
heureusement qu'ils avaient déjà mail
pour l'aider à faire des fautes de
français
est ce que cette mito pas du tout je
vous êtes mégalo ah oui j'ai mal d'or le
parano schizo je suis oui oui un jour je
suis prête un jour je suis sage un jour
juste eu lieu à un accord vous êtes
nympho par périodes sûr que faire si moi
un temps six mois rien du tout aller ce
qu'ils allaient bien schizo ces ados
alors pas encore est ce que vous êtes
maso donc pas du tout gérant tôt c'est
quoi j'ai retenu c'est quand on aime les
vieux a jusque là et ça marche cette
question 50 dans 51
pascal
[Musique]
c'est par ses parts
je ne gêne pas les jeunes voilà très
bien ça tombe bien weight un bonbon
bruno bon c'est bon pour moi est ce que
vous êtes vibro c1 librement non c'est
un téléphone portable
on l'a enfin pour mes 25 ans aalborg à
l'essayer alors ça y est tout seul ouais
on en fait ça vibre mal ouais parce que
ça fait au mieux un mec bien
bah oui courau catherine me dis qu'à ben
non elle est coachée calé dans un trip
hyper romantique qu en ce moment je
prends la productrice de l'émission
questionnaire s'étonne que vous ayez
jamais essayé ce que je suis vraiment
désolé si je m'excuse je vous êtes homo
my way la prusse hilarant commencé sur
le côté entre ce qu'il dit cette
tradition est ce que vous êtes
est ce que vous êtes est ce que vous
êtes homo bah oui non j'ai fait de fait
cet été
ouais c'est tout au tout ouais ça vous a
pas suffisamment plu pour continuer son
appui à mais je préfère les armes
d'ailleurs vous êtes trio là c'était
deux filles par exemple
alors j'ai que ce fantasme de vendée des
gens bah écoute ça tombe bien des cas
y'a du monde là ce soir est ce que vous
êtes
rocco c'est pas la taille qui change
ah bon non mr
alors philippe sollers vous n'êtes pas
au bout de vos peines et vous allez
avoir un traitement que je réserve
d'habitude à de très jeunes filles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien féminin plastique philippe sollers
oui interview psy oui est ce que vous
êtes mytho non je connais trop les
mythes pour être biteau est ce que vous
êtes mégalo je connais trop toutes les
fontes des ressorts de la mégalomanie
pour être vraiment mégalo mais je
comprends la mégalomanie
l'artiste doit être mégalomane mais si
vous êtes parano oui bien sûr comme vous
comme tout le monde comme chacun le
problème est de justifier sa paranoïa et
le problème est là c'est à dire que en
effet toute singularité tout ce qui se
distingue est automatiquement persécutés
donc il faut être parmi les paranoïaques
ont des vrais ennemis aussi des fois oui
c'est vrai non mais c'est pâtissons ça
c'est une phrase de parano mais des fois
il ya d'ailleurs thierry thierry lardât
ouais non plus il est imité il est perçu
pénalité j'ai remarqué un floor motobi
mais oui
les personnels des fonctionnaires défaut
de licence et sa gentille les invités
chaque semaine y en a qui me dit mais
pourquoi votre édition est tellement
copier est ce que vous êtes maso
ça dépend avec la personne qui
trouveraient agréable que je le sois
rubin idée s'il est ce que vous êtes
s'il a bien mais qui s'il a une noisette
sado château ce adorable et panda
personne qui serait un contente que tout
dépend des goûts de l'autre et docile
bien est-ce que vous êtes sous dos ça
dépend de la personne
c'est ce dominant d'accord et c'est très
bien c'est clair est-ce que vous êtes
exhibo à exhibo comme chirac qui se met
à poil
à brégançon non écoutez écoutez c'est
franchement je vois pas pourquoi vous me
comparer à ce personnage
tout à l'heure il a en fait michel leeb
dans le taxi écoutez écoutez et que
celle d'un taxi est ce que vous êtes
gigolo j golo est ce que vous avez fait
gigolo étant jeune oh oui vous êtes fait
des vieilles pour de l'argent au nom des
jeunes pendant sa cp d'eau est ce que
vous êtes gros lolos rhône non pas du
tout ah bon ah non ça tombe bien je dis
est ce que vous êtes trio deux femmes un
homme à la rédac à ils sont tous pareils
allemand mais ça arrive ça plaise ça
arrive que ça plaît bien sûr ça peu
claires est ce que vous êtes
est ce que vous êtes au zoo animaux
imaginairement oui oui oui maintenant
mais dans le discours oui mais pas vrai
non je suis ton chien touchant
temps est bon est ce que vous êtes rocco
au passo mystérieux mother
aux éditions plon
on ne bouge pas dans le ring
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas gérard hier qui a préparé les
questions non mais il aurait pu bon
attention alors est ce que vous êtes
mytho non non non vraiment pas dans là
pas du tout est ce que vous êtes mégalo
je pense un peu tous les gens qui font
ce métier me sens un peu mais pas plus
que ça mais après parano ah oui ça
sûrement voilà c'est pareil on est tous
un peu parano non ce métier on a raison
parce que les paranos ont aussi détruit
si vous êtes schizo non pas du tout non
non vraiment y'a pas de laurent et non
non non je crois pas que je suis même
partout j'ai l'impression vous êtes
nympho non plus et de sado non je pense
je suis plutôt maso est ce vous êtes
exhibo ou pas du tout alors là vraiment
on n'a sûrement pas je vais pas comme
lui qui se dé sap sur les courts et tout
s'annonce sera incapable de faire ce
qu'il a fait là on a vraiment moi je
serais capable de le refaire
non
vous êtes drôles euros qu'est ce ça veut
dire quoi aller une grosse poitrine est
ce que ça veut dire
grenoble non non non et non non non non
non d'ailleurs je préfère des femmes à
petites poitrines genre jane birkin par
exemple que ouais ophélie winter votre
août ali à qui ça thalia à jouer les
jeunes filles et là je n'ai pas remarqué
en fait si vous êtes trio eux passaient
souvent ce que vous êtes travelo non pas
du tout alors annoncer aux branches va
pas c'est pas mon truc la lettre
masturbe au pardon masturber
est ce que j'ai fait tordre au pétard
doba écoutez je l'étais pas j'ai
rencontré un type en noir qui fait de la
cause et ça m'arrive oui de fumée
comment il dit à bourges du jem jour
cyril gêne pas que dans vos émissions
vous poser la question sur le cap à nice
d'accord mais on arrête voilà mais il
faut pas que je bosse après quoi ouais
c'est vraiment vous fumez jamais puisque
vous bossez tout le temps si par exemple
la après l'émission si vous le ferez un
pétage de fées prévenant tier 1
d'ailleurs je crois bien que l'une des
dernières fois où j'en ai fumé c'est ici
avec pierre paul jacques qui était
invité
il
les mauvaises langues
ces deux émissions
mais pire est à venir tina arena nous
allons faire une interview psy ans la
bouche pendant le jihad
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
- est-ce que traductrice 100 sur le coup
ouais sur le coup bien sûr qu'on est sur
le coup 1
belinda pas d'allusion comme ça parce
qu'après ça me chauffer tu sais comment
ça se termine
et oui malheureusement tina est ce que
vous êtes mytho j'ai menti dans ma vie
je suis pas une menteuse
est ce que vous êtes mégalo est ce que
vous êtes parano à meridian ici et ce
malgré 30 juin oui peut-être
vous savez que françois bayrou qui va
être président de la république
française en 2002 et contre le pétard je
veux dire jours thierry j'aime pas quand
vos émissions vous poser la question sur
le cabba niche là ok avec est ce que
vous êtes schizo est ce que vous êtes
cyclo certain moment où je peux l'être
est ce que vous êtes d'infos mais j'aime
bien faire l'amour oui ça c'est sûr oui
oui tout à fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une chanson d une méfiance et une
aventure avec guillaume gille quand la
presse tu me rassures est ce que vous
êtes maso nayais ce nom oui oui je suis
un peu oui bah c'est pour pas dire mais
d'une manière un peu plus modérée sans
vous savez ok c'est bien oui elle répond
donc qu'elle traduit ce qu'elle réponde
pas pour elle si je remercie est ce que
vous êtes sat2way bon c'est une perte de
l'émotion qu'on peut avoir un truc je
voulais en profiter
est-ce qu'on peut être des deux en fait
parce que je sais très écologique ça tu
peux avoir votre arme assez aimé avoir
mal bcc pas assez connaître
c'est inégal 27 au jour où maso moi je
fais tout ce que tu as dit m
[Applaudissements]
tina arena est ce que vous êtes trio non
non ménages à toi non non non je préfère
juste deux personnes s'aiment et bassem
c'est beaucoup et c'est pourquoi ces
neuf ça c'est à ces deux textes pas
belinda est ce que vous êtes porno
annoncé qu'il allait pas
particulièrement je trouve qu'en fait ça
pour beaucoup de goût tout ça mais
peut-être que j'ai pas regardé en
profondeur le porno chic par exemple au
regard de thierry peut-être oui c'était
la maison
dernière question tina arena est ce que
vous êtes lesbo non non est-ce que vous
avez déjà essayé les [ __ ] m'avait
appelé non
[Applaudissements]
tina
ouais
un chant fort interview psy si vous êtes
mito non pour répondre à l'envers alors
pour répondre à l'endroit petit
exactement la vérité est ce que vous
êtes mégalo par moments certainement oui
c'est important de temps en temps sinon
on tente rien quoi je faut il faut il
faut se donner un peu des buts des
choses même un peu improbable va lui
être parano par périodes oui aussi vous
plaît ça ludivine les mecs qui doute qui
sont un peu fragiles comme ça ou vous
préférez les mecs qui croit dur comme
fer en ce qu'ils sont et en ce qu'ils
font j'ai pas besoin des deux moi j'aime
bien avoir le pouvoir de rassurer pour
que moi sommes plein doute
toi tu t'en fous tu vois tes pas
impacter jamais nommée jeune je faisais
déjà vous n'êtes pas trop parano ou ça
va vous avez besoin de problèmes non
mais quand il ya doute y a pas doute oui
donc ça ne faut pas aller par là c'est
tout le doute s'est c'est un luxe le
doute je suis pas un artiste ne s'est
pas un être sensible et délicat non plus
c'est à la limite dans le coup et à ses
pendants crustacés comme on m'a vendu le
marron va faire un jeu du homard tient
parce que le mari par ce soir c'est
commencer il suffit de tomber en m'étant
mettez tout comme ça je vais dans les
mains comme ça aussi je connais ta
musique
attention
mais non
bien à dieu
mais bon
restez donc rempli de nickel blanc par
un garçon qui s'appelle lui même de la
roma il a acheté l'homme à montceau marc
il le paye 50 mille balles et les
cinquante mille balles iront à michaël
blanc qui est emprisonné à ben ali voilà
merci omar s'est dit non
attention est ce que vous êtes maso vous
avez quand vous fasse mal non bah je
n'aime pas avoir mal mais je me suis
aperçu que souvent je le mettais un site
des situations qui n'étaient pas
forcément à mon avantage que j'y
trouvais certainement un certain plaisir
je vous pose même pas la question je
veux pas maso totalement maso avant mais
je leur mets dans mon expression
picturale à mes temps libres à 6,6
qu'est-ce que vous êtes ça donc mesuré
des majeures mesurées quoi sa veste
chaude au nom sympa pas encore juste
après ça vous est ce que vous êtes et
qui bon vous balader à poil dont les
fenêtres dans cloud récent passage non
vous êtes gros lolos bas pansements cela
était mannequinat est clair donc elle
est très grands comme ça très élancée
mais c'est pas très gros lolos c'est
vrai le gros lot je pense qu'il n'y a
pas la refaire
mais si vous êtes trio non papa oui
c'est arrivé mais bon je suis pas là en
ce moment je suis pas trio quoi j'ai
bien avec vous ayez compris que tous vos
questions à la con vous les garder pour
l'autre côté
bien une question qui peut vous
intéresser la malaisie est ce que vous
êtes trop quo c'est-à-dire comparaison
et freddie malheureusement non vous êtes
chamallows chamallows expliquez moi
beaucoup je n'avais failli à paille a
pas d'intermédiaire cydia mais la
saint-jean fort
non mesdames et messieurs voici le
moment que toute la france attend c'est
l'interview psid hélène ségara
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous êtes en souk aux
monstres simplement à ce que vous êtes
maniaco non au grand désespoir des
beaucoup et pas dicter du désordre
ouais c'est vrai que tu changes non ce
métrage allemand semble est ce que vous
êtes mytho j'aime pas ça non non mégalo
bazas et va au bout de certains moi je
suis piccolo le sang sans déranger 1
ça fait maintenant vingt minutes
j'attends mon verre puisque cette mode
saas en c1 puisque vous êtes parano
c'est non mais c'est un combat dans ce
métier je m'excuse aux non pas du tout
vous êtes cyclo j'ai plutôt bien longs
mois attention enfin parlons pas de vélo
c'est ce qui se passe quand tu entends
très bien est ce que vous êtes
l'info non non je mais par amour on peut
le devenir d'un faux mais je jugeais non
je suis pas d'infos et quoi maso maso et
par amour aussi en pole devenir non j'ai
pas maison comme un petit peu ne
m'attendais pas mal surtout pas attacher
fouetter mais un petit peu mal du
pincement comme ça tout du tout mes
petites sauf pour exceptionnellement
pour venir ici ce soir
est ce que vous êtes ça ne vous aimez
faire mal cas pas du tout mais pour une
[ __ ] est que ce soir je vais devenir un
exhibo v nous balader à poil et
intrépide au moins à très peu d'eau
bon je m'en donne si vous êtes pédo
parce qu'avec damien c'était un petit
peu de la poursuite d'un pédo du toucher
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai honte de moi
mon fils que je suis trop maman pour
être violent et d'eau est ce que vous
êtes gigolo un nom mais si au just one
si jeune si je le fus se fût inconscient
voile d'accord je m'en bat vous êtes
vibro non non est ce que vous êtes lesbo
non non mais j'ai mes garçons aux
cheveux longs dans fait qu'il ya quelque
chose à creuser boys et délégations
félin aux cheveux loin c'est vrai ça est
ce que vous êtes pétards d'eau si jamais
fumé un pétard
j'en suis super fier parce que je peux
dire que la grand mère ma grand mère et
ma mère qui m'ont éduqué m'ont pas
éduqué pour rire je suis très heureuse
comme ça
tiens je vais dire un truc pardon au
sujet des pétards on parle souvent de
pétards dans cette émission le buteur ce
papa plus grave qu'un verre de whisky en
revanche en revanche il ya maintenant
des produits qui viennent d'amsterdam
qui sont enrichis en thc et qui sont
très dangereux
th et le thc c'est le principe qui
défonce dans le dans le chic quoi tuer
et ils sont enrichis d'une façon
scientifique et tu veux et ça faut
vraiment faire gaffe voilà je vais dire
ça si moi par exemple j'ai mes petits
mais petit gré main mais petit héros
demanderai fume un peu de bordel et à
coup ils me disent tiens venu ici je
suis pop je suis pas tellement ça
c'était chez pas quoi je te jure que
j'ai dans ma chambre d'hôtel j'ai fait
une taffe comme ça je dis bon bah je
vais me coucher je suis rentré dans la
chambre d'hôtel j'avais la télécommande
comme ça je voyais à la télé et jeté
dans la télé
c'est vraiment possible de zapper je
regardais un truc lamentable à la télé
comme ça je fais avant le possible
impossible de mettre couverture sur moi
j'ai été gelés comme ça je suis resté
deux heures un cauchemar invraisemblable
est ce que vous êtes sanglots oui voila
je sais je sais un petit peu vous voulez
en venir c'est que c'est vrai que je
pleure facilement mais non chez motive
mais par contre je comme je suis pudique
je pleurais en public je peux pleurer
que de joies mes chagrins je les
montrerai jamais est ce que vous êtes
orlando ah oui furlan d'eau le jour où
je serai plus ça sera peut-être la fin
mais je suis orlando jeudi j'ai même dit
que le jour il a en outre tué hélène
à voir maintenant larry hagman comment
va votre santé mentale
on va faire une interview psy dans les
bouches là pour l'homme de gauche m'a
cependant le jingle de couche tard ne
bouge pas couchepin
le graphisme la fois je galvanise métro
et un souci avec le béatrice mme arrêter
ben fist
et bien c'est pas bien le savez très
bien allez on n'a pas l'habitude de
prendre les moches
alors attention
larry est ce que vous êtes mito n'a
jamais joué non de la sla est ce que
vous êtes
mégalo yash oui parano non est ce que
vous êtes schizo mais je mélange mais
les acteurs font tout ça bonjour vous
êtes d'accord
vous êtes bien est-ce que vous êtes
nympho n'en est pas encore à est ce que
vous êtes maso non olympique alors lâche
pas
j'aime pas la douleur sadow nador est
guéri
j'aime pas faire donner de la douleur
est ce que vous êtes seaux d'eau
non
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous êtes gros lolos bien que
je parle de ses coûts de ces gourous
pardon est ce que vous êtes trio mais
sans remise en bon alors vous êtes à
paris à paris paris si je suis le seul
mec est ce que vous êtes homo nature il
a plein de trucs à faire encore est ce
que vous êtes zoo est encore très flou
[Rires]
larry est ce que vous êtes
rocco ou chamallows donc la tradition
rabbinique j'ai trop connu
c'est une star du porno en france c'est
vrai wouah les deux mois les grands
ensembles al kent voilà pourquoi pas is
like que ce qu'il faut ça vient me faut
un écran
si la mission
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous êtes mito non est ce que
vous êtes mégalo oui vous êtes parano
non est ce que vous êtes schizo non est
ce que vous êtes cyclo non je vous êtes
nympho je vous êtes maso oui je vous ai
tous à dos parce que je suis censé
développer les réponses m'expédie en
cinq minutes je ne dis pas ça après un
petit peu qu'elle vaudra qui tardent ou
bien trop de terrain qui va jeter sa
gourme jeunes en étaient à un stade au
oui pourrait-on dire non ah bon mais pas
que
non non est ce que vous êtes l'exhibent
au nom des trios vous êtes homo non zoo
a fait pas mal de blur est ce que vous
êtes prêts pour une interview psy
vous êtes désespérant michel field est
ce que vous êtes mito un petit peu
mégalo énormément votre définition on
peut pas l'être un peu parano en
septembre dernier peut-être un petit peu
et bien passé il va bien pété les plombs
vite maso ça dépend avec qui veut ça
vous déplaît pas
rien de ce qui est humain ne m'est
étranger ouais c'est ça dos alors même
réponse il est so do so do vous
l'écrivez comment parce que si c'est
pour avoir un peu d'eau dans la gueule
quand on fait chaud lui voler ses solos
l'été xibaut j'aimerais j'aimerais bien
être suffisamment bons pour donner du
plaisir à des gens qui marchent mais
j'ai renoncé à cette vision et cette vie
bros ça peut arriver ouais gros lolos
oui j'ai des trios oui elle était sûre
avec lui et soit trop c'est une course à
l'atome julie cleo je vous en prie je
meurs il est plutôt roko ukic a mal au
fc m'arrive d'être chamallows après
avoir été rocco
il ya longtemps que je vous attends dans
cette émission pour une interview et 6
à gauche
les dégâts
est ce que vous êtes mythos dans mon
travail j'essaie de dire ce que je pense
mais en même temps comme je suis
romancier j'utilise la fiction ouais
donc je fais une réponse y entrent je
suis un mensonge qui dit la vérité
donc je mange avec beaucoup de sincérité
voilà vous me dîtes si ça suffit pas
vous arbitrez judith est ce que vous
êtes mégalo maîtresses judith n'est très
uni est ce que vous êtes mais diallo oui
complètement
ben oui sinon ça se voit pas maintenant
je bosse j'essaie d'être le plus humble
et ses montres la glace ouais mais c'est
comme l'ump en ce moment et je sais de
30 maison du marin le matin en me
réveillant je me regarde dans la glace
je baisse les yeux je regardais voilà je
vous le fais là non tirées non je suis
pas mégalo
est ce que vous êtes parano pourquoi
vous me posez cette question est ce que
vous êtes schizo oui parce que j'ai
envie de c'est pas que je me disperse
mais je pense qu en fait j'aimerais bien
avoir des homonymes et et avoir le don
d'ubiquité
voila voila mon rêve c'est ça est ce que
vous êtes maso
j'y travaille allez à canal+ est un
début
je
simplement je suis très douillet alors
je sais pas si j'aurai le courage
vraiment et c'est agréable d'être maso
je crois enfin les vrais masochiste sont
des gens très paresseux qui sont
attachés on s'occupe de 6
c'est pas mal ça do we will un terme à
la course à la mairie
oui c'est agréable mais c'est fatigant
c'est l'avantagé pour ça je dis maso
c'est mieux parce qu'on n'a rien à faire
le sadi qui à la fin de la soirée
oui c'est glauque quoi voilà exactement
il faut bosser à voici est ce que vous
êtes
so do so do alors oui je suis au dos je
suis actif passif et cette réponse va
rester dans les annales et que vous êtes
vibro je ne vois pas de raison de ne pas
avoir recours aux progrès de la science
[Applaudissements]
c'est tout ce que j'aurais à dire là
dessus
est ce que vous êtes homo mais on a dans
un journal en 20 ans qualifié de hétéro
[ __ ]
oui on va se qualifier de quoi dans 20
ans salariée vieux travelo ben non mais
je me suis habillé en femme pour une
soirée le bal des débutantes
ouais et j'étais superbe avec une robe
emprunté et je ressemblais à valérie
lemercier dans palace ça fera plaisir
si tu nous regardes est ce que vous êtes
trio non je suis 17 au 22 août
mais je vois pas l'intérêt de se limiter
à trois personnes telles que est ce que
vous êtes zoo je suis en fait pédo zone
et cros quintaux scatophile c'est à dire
que j'aime bien manger de la merde de
jeunes chiens morts pour me juger qui
êtes vous il faudrait que chacun ses
petites habitudes oui en même temps
c'est tellement service public on veut
pas lui jeter la pierre
original
est ce que vous êtes mito non est ce que
vous êtes mégalo non plus c'est à dire
il faut il faut quand même confiance en
soi pour faire ça si on ne peut pas
monter sur scène et se livraient mettre
100 % de ce qu'on est
si on n'a pas une confiance en ce qu'on
peut donner un appui de mélissa voutaz
dirais moi j'ai été primé à 13 ans elle
elle l'a été
ouais ouais on connait pas suspecte ah
non moi je suis entre au conservatoire
13 ans je n'ai pas encore pris mais je
vous aide pas à nos à huy assez
facilement
là par exemple non vous pensez pas que
la terre entière vous annonce non pas
par rapport à un complexe qu'un complexe
de persécution par rapport à une
obsession du détail est ce que vous êtes
schizo non pas du tout josiane à hélène
grimaud de la musique la laine grimaud
des loups n'ont absolument pas du tout
est ce que vous êtes un port l'houmeau
mais non ce n'est pas de carton rouge je
n'ai plus rien est ce que vous êtes
cateau non est ce que vous êtes maniaco
oui enfin ça dépend si vous voulez la
maniaco dépressive non ouais maniaco
louis locaux est ce que vous êtes
narciso non plus pour y est pourtant
est-ce que vous êtes fétiche aux non
plus bien vous êtes assez normal mais
alors oui normal non moi j'ai toujours
essayé de
comme il ya deux mains libres et de l'
esclavage par rapport à certaines
certains objets d'être attaché des
choses matérielles
donc en fait le fétichisme ce n'est pas
pour moi c'est moi vous êtes celle ou
non maso non moi il ya une certaine
jouissance dans la souffrance
mais c'est une passion de s'élever ouais
vous n'êtes pas sado maso non vous êtes
trop co je suis quoi rococo elle vous
êtes trio non un petit quatre mains
quand même maintenant je suis trio dans
l'esprit de la visite
oui j'aime bien n'hésite plus rien
gardons ces tests yazid le fantasme et
des mystères série restant là est ce que
vous êtes zowie ça suffit aussi j'ai
fait plein d'animaux c'est bon non mise
au pas au nom parce que jo c'est quand
même réducteur
est ce que vous êtes adamo qu'est ce que
c'est c'est pareil
tiscali c'est ce qu'elle fit j'étais
d'accord à poils durs cd démo vous êtes
exhibo non moi c'était mal non plus est
ce que vous êtes
magnéto ah oui ah oui j'aime
l'enregistrement
[Musique]
marie-ange alors sénateur loppsi est ce
que vous êtes
mythos non pas du tout non non alors
vraiment pas du tout pas du tout me tôt
dans l'histoire du lion jamais vu les
images est ce que vous êtes très diallo
non plus non plus le nom de parano un
soupçon a pas trop pas trop non
la preuve deux ans et demi de placard
pour savoir pourquoi vous êtes schizo
petit peu il ya deux marie ange nardi
une magnifique bonne celle là était chez
le toiletteur vous êtes très bien
coiffée j'adore les créoles en plus moi
donc en excuser quand même oui un petit
peu oui
après disons que c'est un personnage à
plusieurs facettes il ya celles qu'on
connaît la télévision comme ça
l'animatrice préférée des français les
pilot de façade c'est quoi c'est
quelqu'un peut être un peu plus un peu
plus
un peu plus fou que ce que les gens
imaginent met volontiers sa journée
l'impression sa frappe et commence pas
forcément que des bonnes choses un pas
que de la bonne à bonbons c'est pas que
sexuels n'ont pas caché qu ciel je
comprends rien est ce que vous êtes
cyclo un petit peu mais je ne fais pas
vivre sous abri c'est bien ce soir vous
êtes plutôt en haut ça va ouais ça c'est
plutôt bien
est ce vous êtes maso non vraiment je
n'ai pas qu'on vous fasse mal non non
non je peux m'énerver assez fort parce
que je suis agressive méchant dans
l'amour par exemple si un mec vous fait
mal à ça c'est pas l'agresser non mais
j'avais pas compris c'est faire du
psycho mais uniquement sur le plan d'eau
je voudrais pas c'est la clé tôt il est
donc mal non mal non un vrai match va
laisser le temps que les taux varient
bats toi je ne vais pas que c'est
dommage je ne vais pas non j'ai sado
vous aimez bien faire mal non ah bon
sado maso
[Rires]
là j'en ai une effectivement je vous
êtes l'info
qu est ce qu on vous entend exactement
par l'info une femme qui veut pas se
passer du sexe de l'homme qui en a
besoin jour et nuit tous les chats place
vous voulez dire par rapport aux hommes
ont tous les hommes sont les autres
termes on l'entend habituellement non
pléthore d'hommes non non c'est quoi
l'océan
c'est une info à l'arc en ciel de
combien c'est pas tous les torts c'est
très relatifs à chaque individu pour ses
bons chiffres et je peux pas le nier
c'est mon chiffre porte-bonheur
vous êtes exhibo n'en a pas du tout non
dit lesbo non non ah ouais ben
finalement trio non plus non plus
gérante aux ménages non mais j'ai pas
encore essayé non plus tout ça c'est du
mariage mais c'est un appel que vous
faites si vous branchez par les
quinquagénaires les cageots sauratois
excuse et obispo gelais était plutôt
début mai deux mois qu'elle en est
ressorti oui c'est bien c'est bien fait
c'est dur il ya des patchs maintenant je
crois vous êtes rocco chamallows annonce
qu elle a avoué avoir tiré
leur essai rsa
longueuil
[Musique]
ça va
bien on va faire une interview psy
d'accord à terme ou psy
m
est ce que vous êtes mythos est ce que
vous êtes
mégalo non plus est ce que vous êtes
paranos un peu non
ouais schizo non cyclo cyclomoteur petit
me oui je continue je n'avais pas mes
fils je m'excuse mans avec akli tôt je
suis là j'ai eu quelques straw ouais
maniaco non maso non plus bob a un peu
quand même
j'ai été naïve temps dans quatre réseaux
pour venir la folle être un peu quand
même
c'est vrai parce que vous êtes gérons
tout ça c'est pour nous désirons tôt non
qu'elle agit l'alpil jeunes que nous à
oui bon donc lé jeu no way donc elle est
là j'adore les gigots peut-être m'amuser
gigolo il va plus jeune que vous alors
tout va bien vous êtes vibro j'ai essayé
mais sans succès ah ouais ben sur le
portable vous êtes rocco êtes piccolo ou
rocco roncquois c tro ar en sait trop
comment tu avais mon jean marie bigard
bien de temps en temps mais pas toujours
mais des fois c'est pas mal quand même
assez souvent mais c'est pas toujours de
quoi est mort y est vous nous parler ce
soir est bien de mon prochain spectacle
qui s'appelle mon psy va mieux au
comédia au comédia à partir du 15
répondre ead
si je vous demande de me raconter un
souvenir d'enfance n'importe lequel ce
serait quoi bon mon meilleur souvenir
d'enfance c'est la première fois que
qu'une fille m'a attrapé les roubignoles
j'ai trouvé ça extraordinaire parce que
tu peux pas le raconter ça s'écrit pas
un je me suis dit si c'est ça la vie et
ben je suis d'accord pour continuer
c'est quoi l'expérience la plus
traumatisante de ta vie at elle assuré
la main voilà plus de dix ans de ma vie
c'était de perdre mes parents mais
encore une fois je les analyse et d'une
manière puisque c'est une interview au
psy je pense que c'est les étages de la
fusée qui se détache pour que la fusée
aïe plus haut et après coup donc trente
ans plus tard je me dis mais si j'avais
pas perdu mais mes parents jamais serait
monté marie jamais j'aurai connu laurent
baffie thierry ardisson toi non mais
c'est tout à fait acquis les autres de
dire ben ça ne s'est pas savoir les
abonnés un truc très important c'est que
tout arrive pour le mieux y compris le
plus gros des emmerdements
tu as le choix ou de l'accepter ou de
renâcler et tu peu renâclé toute ta vie
quelque chose de mauvais qui t'es arrivé
ou alors tu peux te dire voilà une
épreuve de la franchise je suis digne de
franchir l'obstacle donc je le franchie
dès l'enfance a eu besoin d'être et mr
bah je suis arrivé en costume
ouais tous mes frères et soeurs ils sont
arrivés tout tordu le feu lui tirer
dessus et où moi je suis avait pas il a
fallu digérer sur le cordon bon ben je
me claque dans le mur
je suis arrivé j'ai fait et hop oui
parce que c'est le quatrième âge était
pas tellement désiré donc tu arrivé en
disant attendait me jetez pas tout de
suite grâce à un drôle c'est pour ça que
je suis c'est pour ça que je suis
comique c'est pour ça aussi que très
souvent les artistes les grands artistes
des grands créateurs grade créateurs ne
sont presque jamais les premiers de la
famille puisque le premier tube uzi
toujours un petit peu sans vie qui soit
comme toi tu as envie qu'ils fassent pas
les conneries que tu as fait tu
comprends donc le dernier comme les
trois autres d'avant ils ont déjà bien
déblayé le terrain
le quatrième année que ces expériences
lui libre il ce besoin de choquer tu
m'expliques comment mes valeurs ont tué
non je n'ai pas besoin je ne je me
considère pas comme quelqu'un de
choquant ah oui pas dit non non si si à
moins que l'on n'ait jamais torcher le
cul d'un vieux à moins qu'on ait jamais
fait des trucs
qu'est-ce que vous avez encore du mal à
contrôler dans la vie mais colère ouais
vous êtes quoi les relais l'injustice
ouais ouais et la colère ça j'ai du mal
à régler le curseur vite j'ai eu envie
de mourir
jean-marie j'ai tout le temps un petit
peu envie ça me déplaît pas oui non mais
l'idée même des becs la vérité comme je
le dis dans mon siège est vraiment pas
peur de la mort j'ai peur comme tout le
monde de souffrir que ça dure longtemps
d'avoir une déchéance toi longue et
pénible et tout mais sinon le mort si
elle vient aujourd'hui elle est la
bienvenue
le plus tard sera le mieux parce que je
suis pas suicidaire mais ouais mais ça
me fait pas peur elle vient quand il
veut je l'attend cet [ __ ] là
qu'avez-vous enfin compris sur vos j'ai
compris que je n'étais que une toute
petite partie de l'univers qu'il fallait
pas trop s'affoler et que la vie était
vraiment
jeu et que le mieux c'était de jouer
encore ouais vous acceptez bien ne pas
avoir d'enfant bah je l'acceptent
en tout cas j'ai les enfants des autres
et puis d'avoir le sien n'est jamais sûr
que c'est le sien ouais si je vais dire
un truc un frein contrôle sur le sur
l'ensemble de la planète on
s'apercevrait que s'est passé ces mamans
sur pas peut-être
et puis on peut toujours adopter les
enfants des autres et les filiales
absolument par exemple ça déjà été tenté
par une aventure avec un homme
non franchement non c'est un truc de
monsieur c'est physique
je suis pas je suis pas contre 1 ont des
fois on s'embrasse quand on fait les
cons sans voix sur la bouche etc la
langue on le fait un coup tous les deux
c'est cet attrait pour le sexe la taille
du sexe sur vos affiches de spectacles
etc s'est trahi pas une angoisse par
rapport à la taille réelle à votre sexe
nono non parce que c'était vraiment pour
rigoler j'ai mis des balles de tennis
j'ai un sexe qui est énorme a refait
j'en suis assez content pourquoi vous
avez besoin de toucher les couilles tout
le temps jean-marie mais pourquoi tu dis
ça
maintenant on va vérifier si emmanuelle
gaume à un problème d'instabilité
interview pied dans la bouche pendant
les mandats bush
on ne bouge pas pendant les problèmes ne
bouge pas pendant le dingle connard moi
c'est laurent mais je suis ravi de
connaître ton prénom on va t'appeler
connaît maintenant ça va très vite
est-ce que vous êtes mégalo
petit chou et un petit chou c'est à dire
un petit chouya j'apprends ici c'est
bien oui c'est bien non il faut venir
tous les samedis vision l'approbation du
service public
est ce que vous êtes mito menteuse
j'adore sales mensonges
parano en ces périodes de l'année un peu
mercato est ce que vous êtes schizo non
j'ai un wiiware vrai don d'ubiquité je
préfère ubiquité à schizophrénie
geoffrey nice est plus proche de la
folie j'ai pas du tout dingue tu arrives
à suivre c'est parce que vous êtes cyclo
cyclothymique
ouais mais aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est
la peau d'âne là à l'instant présent
superbe maintenant c'était totalement
d'armes mais ça va je pleure rit moi
mais c'est comme ça c'est pas mal comme
la vie comme les filles très méfiant
comme nous aussi parce que on espèces ou
alignement des scellés pendant cinq
minutes on y va
entre temps il écrit ses classiques
aussi donc c'est important
bien sûr moi je crois pas vivre sans ou
l'école de foot un petit truc là nous
mais pas fait que j'aime bien s'y prêter
c'est pour quitter parce que je vais
bien est ce que vous êtes maso ah non
des must est ce que vous êtes exhibo qui
chauffe est bien petit chaussée c'est
quoi c'est beaucoup pour seagate lesbo
non pas des chiens non pas du tout je
suis vraiment été arrêté au bord d un
pas du tout genre du ca s vous êtes ado
j'adore les ados j'adore les enfants
géronto non c'est vraiment un truc est
ce que vous êtes trio un trio fou non
franchement non vous êtes quoi je suis
très classique vraiment non plus belle
pour vous un adieu moureu way soumettre
au co les grosses grosses l'annoncé par
un truc rien du tout alors non
est ce que vous êtes adamo alain boudou
[Musique]
est finalement alors donc vous êtes une
fille très très normal finalement pas
beaucoup de perversion noms ne disent
rien les jules et julot oui mais voilà
les coquettes sur canal
dans tous les cas sur france
avec drôle de gars cochet l'émission le
6 juin
michel blanc et le 12 juin avec
dominique a maintenant vous avez que
c'est baffie la bâche y revient
wisekey la montre est vu comme ça je
pourrai juger sur fixe
[Musique]